le gouvernement a opté pour un plan de
déconfinement en quatre étapes étalées
sur les mois de mai et de juin
il donne un avant-goût de retour à une
vie presque normale
déjà connue la date du 3 mai marquera la
fin des restrictions sur les
déplacements en journée qui était jusque
là limitée à un rayon de 10 km à cette
date les français pourront aussi
recommencé à se rendre dans d'autres
régions
les collégiens et les lycéens quant à
eux réintégreront comme prévu les bancs
de l'école
selon la règle des demies jauge deuxième
étape décisive pour les professionnels
de la restauration et le milieu culturel
la reprise de l'activité à la mi mai
n'est plus un mirage
emmanuel macron a finalement dévoilé la
date tant attendue à partir du 19 mai il
sera donc à nouveau possible de se
prélasser à 6 autour d'une même table de
partager un verre ou un repas en
terrasse uniquement peut-être même à la
sortie d'un spectacle ou d'une séance de
cinéma puisque à cette date les lieux
culturels rouvriront aussi des
réouvertures qui se feront sous
conditions avec des jo de visiteurs à
respecter les activités sportives de
plein air et en intérieur pourront
reprendre également suivant un protocole
adapté et surtout le couvre-feu passera
à 21h il sera donc à nouveau possible de
flâner dans les rues après le travail
troisième étape le 9 juin le télétravail
sera assouplie les sportifs pourront
retrouver leurs salles de sport et les
gastronomes l'intérieur des salles de
restaurants et des bars le couvre-feu
devrait quant à lui être décalé jusqu'à
23 heures
emmanuel macron a aussi tranché la
question du pass sanitaires le président
ne veut pas qu'il soit obligatoire pour
les restaurants mais il souhaite laurent
nécessaire pour l'accès au stade
festival ou foire qui pourront
accueillir jusqu'à 5000 personnes sur
présentation du précieux sésame impasse
qui sera aussi une condition d'accès à
la france pour les touristes étrangers
pour les français les plus noctambules
il faudra attendre la quatrième et
dernière étape dès le 30 juin
ils pourront de nouveau profité de la
nuit le couvre-feu prendra fin les
événements extérieurs et intérieurs
de plus de mille personnes seront
autorisées là encore sans présentation
du pass sanitaires un plan de
déconfinement qui donne de l'espoir mais
qui reste sujet à caution le
gouvernement ne révisera toutes les
trois semaines pour l'adapter si besoin
aux évolutions de la situation sanitaire